what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to lil
naz axe that's what i want before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos as you guys
know i'm making a move to london pretty
quick so each and every subscriber
really helps me make a living here on
youtube so
help a girl out subscribe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay these people look way too old to be
in high school
like this isn't even slightly believable
like can we at least do college this has
got to be
a college
[Music]
oh wow
oh that
that escalated so fast it was like hi
hello and
oh wow oh dear
[Music]
[Music]
at least they promote the condom in
there um
wow that's a
interesting scene they got going on
[Music]
okay i really like the guitar in this i
think that sounds really cool
[Music]
[Music]
wait now they're
camping so they just met
had sex in the locker room
and and now they're can't like i'm so
confused are they dating now i'm not
wanting anything but you're loving your
body and a little
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
man had a whole family
[Music]
is
[Music]
i want
someone to love
me
i need
someone who needs me
i was like who's the lucky fella but i
guess i i guess nobody
someone is
[Music]
okay
i gotta say that music video was 10 out
of 10. i was
entertained like the entire time
um some oh shoot some scenes took me
like
like wow escalated quickly
overall i liked the song i liked the
music video
i'm gonna give that a 5 out of 5.
um
my only complaint is like i kind of like
a happy ending
uh
not like that no we were thinking like
like in the end of the story like i was
really hoping he'd find like somebody
who loved him
like he was looking for in the song
but you know i guess
not everybody finds someone some people
end up alone so
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree um don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time